good morning John and thank you for your
video on Monday and which you tribute us
to a glimpse of the magnificently
complicated world that defines the lives
of small plants that happen to produce
fibrous strands of cellulose that can be
converted into things like me and that
is mind-blowing I mean it's cotton and
you didn't even scratch the surface of
how complicated the actual global cotton
industry is the number of people things
and complexities necessary to turn you
know like sunlight air and soil into a
shirt you don't even want to know it or
eyes here's something that you said to
me recently you said Hank it comes down
to the fact that the truth resists
simplicity and you're always saying
marvelous things like that and it's
always very frustrating because for me
to come up with marvelous things like
that I have to be like typing for hours
and hours and hours and then I'll be
like oh that's a good that's one good
thing that I came up with but that's why
you're the professional writer and I'm
the professional goofball feel like can
you do something now to prove that I'm
the professional goofball maybe I'll
just ah anyway I just love that the
truth resists simplicity I love it I
love it especially because it's a simple
truth talking about how rare simple
truths are if they're word for that it
feels like there should be a word for
that I'm not the writer nerdfighters
comments tell me if there's a word for
that we like to think that the most
complicated things that we've ever
learned are the hard sciences like math
and physics and chemistry but really
those are the simple things because at
least there's definite answers at least
of the level we're learning about in
high school now that I think about a
chemistry in physics and math there's a
lot of stuff that's not definite but
what's even more complicated than that
is like history and your history teacher
gives you a test and there's there's a
question it says what were the
implications of the Magna Carta
nobody freaking knows the answer to that
question may be without the Magna Carta
we'd all be Nazis maybe we'd all be dead
maybe we're avoiding an evil race of
genetically engineered space monsters
maybe we'd all be drinking pig's milk
for breakfast probably not what there's
good reasons why we don't drink pigs
milk
like really like what well it's
complicated
oh of course it's complicated what
what's so complicated about it what I do
with a lot of different stuff like the
reproductive system of the pigs and the
practice of reading pigs generally for
me - not for dairy even the reason we
don't drink pigs milk is complicated Wow
thanks doc I had no idea that you were
such a specialist on pig milking
practices well there's a lot of stuff
you don't know about me we love
simplicity and we want simple stories
like we want there to be a homeless man
the golden voice that was never
recognized for his talent until the
internet found him when in actuality
it's a story of a man who went to school
and worked hard to develop his voice and
made a thousand bad decisions that led
to him becoming homeless not because no
one recognized his talent but because he
was addicted to alcohol and drugs we
want the untainted love of Edward and
Bella to be both perfect and immortal
and it can be because it's fake we want
simple solutions this intelligent
looking Asian man for example thinks
maybe they could power the entire
amusement park with a hybrid drive even
though that would violate the third law
of thermodynamics apparently people at
Toyota's advertising don't know about
it's the one where you can't create
energy from nothing and we want to make
simple assumptions about the tragedy in
Tucson we want to fit it into our
simplistic worldview where we can blame
the people we're already blaming when
really it's just a breakdown in the most
complicated system probably in the known
universe the human brain and that same
system so thoroughly damaged somehow
still functioning and congresswoman
giffords proving once again that the
truth resists simplicity I think one of
the principal facets of being a mature
and healthy and effective person is
understanding that you are almost always
wrong you might have be all the way
wrong but at least a little bit you're
always a little bit wrong we as a
species don't know the answer to the
vast majority of questions and it turns
out that one of the hardest parts of all
this and possibly the most important
part is accepting that we don't have
those answers and that our simple little
explanations are flawed sometimes
dangerously flawed especially when we
start talking about political news
analysis thanks John for making you
think about all that stuff I'm gonna go
play Lego Harry Potter now because there
I know the difference between good and
evil John I'll see you on Friday